It took me over five years to make over
$9,000 in profits in a single month of
trading. Today, I'm going to walk you
through the four steps that if I had
followed when I first started out would
have got me there 10 times faster. When
I first started out, I'd watch videos
exactly like this one. Always looking
for some quick tip or shortcut, but that
mindset really slowed me down. So, I
challenge you to really listen to
everything I say. The real breakthroughs
aren't hidden in the bullet points. They
are understanding the nuances and the
little steps that are inside each bullet
point. Especially the last step where
I'm going to show you exactly how to
scale your trading account. If you just
skim it, you'll likely miss out on key
steps that actually make it work. Now,
the first big bullet point is quantity
over quality. This can seem super basic
when you first start out, and in some
sense it really is. But I know from
experience and teaching other people how
to trade, everyone goes through that
process of, "Okay, I've heard that it
makes sense." But the reality is
everyone approaches trading in the wrong
way of trying to be reactionary to the
market and what it's doing. When I first
started out trading, I tried to look at
all the moves in the market and try and
see how I could capture each one. If it
was a really strong setup or kind of an
okay setup, I would still take them
because what I wanted to do is I wanted
to capture as many moves as possible.
And that what I didn't realize was
instead to really become consistent over
time and it took me years of losing to
have this really driven into me is you
don't need to be taking 20 trades in a
day. You can take one trade a week and
be consistently profitable over the long
run. This is a marathon that you are
starting or trying to do. Treat it like
one. You do not need to be treating it
like a sprint. It's all about timing
when it comes to it. And some days or
weeks are just not good for trading.
It's all about trying to have it fit how
you want to trade. Especially when it
comes to when you're first starting out.
Treat every trade like you're in a
really big account or like it's real
money. If you're starting out on a demo
account, if you wouldn't take that trade
on a real money account or a really
large real money account, don't take the
trade because the reason why you're
taking it is you think it's not that big
of a deal. And you know, the idea is,
oh, you know, it kind of might work out.
The only trades you should be getting in
are the ones you really, really believe
in and that you know are going to be
really, really good. I've done that
countless times where I get in a not
great trade. I still want to jump in and
try and capture that move because what
if it does work out? Another big thing
when you first start out is don't
overrisk per trade. Don't change how
much you're risking per trade. you know,
don't risk 50% of your account on one
trade. What you need to do is you need
to risk a small amount so your account
can slowly grow over time. As well with
this is when you're in a trade and you
have placed a specific stop-loss based
on your strategy, do not move that
stop-loss farther away, increasing your
risk per trade. It's really common to
get married to a trade to where you
think it's going to really work out and
it's still looking good and you know
maybe the market just needs to go
against you a tiny bit and I've done
that plenty of times and every time it
just makes it so I lost more on the
trade and if I got out where I
originally had it I would have got out
at less and the signal for the trade not
being good anymore was where I was
originally going to get out. It sucks
having a trade that looks so good go
against you and not work out to be a
really big winner. But that's a part of
trading. You don't know when things are
going to work out in your favor. At the
end of the day, we're trying to play the
math game and statistically things are
going to work out some of the time and
not some of the time and you don't know
when that's going to be. I was micro
scalping and trying to take 20 trades a
day and risk a large amount to make a
small amount. And I originally thought,
well, if it's a short distance go for
profit, well, it'll be easy for me to
get that profit. But statistically over
time, it made me so, you know, my wins
were really small and my losses were
bigger than my wins. And what this did
to me mentally, every time I took a
loss, it felt horrible because it would
wipe out multiple wins. It would take me
three wins to wipe out a loss and get a
little bit in the profit. And when it
comes to trading, the mental side is
extremely important because every
decision you make can be influenced by
your emotions. And if you're frustrated,
it's super easy to make bad decisions,
which is something that derails so many
traders from being consistently
profitable. And so when it comes to your
riskreward, I highly suggest starting
out with either a one to two risk-reward
ratio where you're risking $100 to make
$100. Statistically, you're break even
at a 50/50% win rate, which mentally is
a lot better. Same thing if I would also
recommend going one to two riskreward
ratio initially as well if that's what
you would prefer where you're risking
$100 to make $200. I think that's even
better because you only need a 33% win
rate to be consistently break even and
above that you're consistently
profitable with a 40 or 50% win rate.
And mentally, it makes it so your losses
aren't as big of a deal. For me, losing
and having that mental struggle of, oh,
what if I get in this trade and I was
wrong? Having that pressure on every
trade was a lot easier when I could say,
well, if I lose, it's okay. I am
actually based on my riskreward I'm
supposed to lose a majority of the time
which seems really funny but
mathematically it plays out in the end.
Now before we go on to the next step I
have created a 90-day trader road map.
This will lay out everything that you
should go through and focus on other
than this video over the next 90 days.
It'll give you a stepbystep process of
what you should be doing on the road to
becoming a consistently profitable
trader. I'll leave a link for it in the
description below this video or you can
download it for free using this QR code
as well. Now, I think the number one
thing that stops traders from being
consistently profitable is jumping from
strategy to strategy. I did this for
years. I would watch a YouTube video,
take a course, and try and focus and
learn on a strategy, and I would not be
consistently profitable doing it. And
so, I would then move on to the next
strategy. Well, what this did is it
would start me over from step one.
Again, in reality, trading takes a long
time to become consistently profitable
at. Even if you're taking a strategy
from an experienced trader that is
consistently profitable doing it,
everyone approaches trading differently.
We all have different emotions that
affect how we trade differently. I get
scared to jump into a trade because I'm
nervous that I'm making the wrong
decision. Well, maybe you know you're a
person that once you're in a trade,
you're greedy and let the thing go on
too long and you give up your profits or
you take larger losses because you move
your stop loss farther and farther away
because you get married to the trade and
want to let it play out more. Everyone
is different and so that's why it takes
a long time to become consistent with a
strategy and so you have to stick to one
strategy otherwise you're going to get
stuck in what I actually call now a
learning loop of trying to learn
infinite things about the market. That's
the thing about trading is there are so
many time frames, so many indicators.
And what this all does is it really
makes infinite ways to approach trading
the market. And so how I actually ended
up breaking out of this was after a long
losing streak of struggling and just
feeling defeated, I went back to the
drawing board and said, "Okay, what am I
actually good at?" And I felt I was good
at seeing where key levels of support
and resistance were. I felt that I could
consistently mark those on my chart and
look for reversals at those levels. I
felt more confident trading reversals
than continuation type trades. And so
what I did was then I spent a couple
years developing my own style of okay,
how do I profit off of these levels that
I'm confident in and that I can draw
really well? And so that's where I came
up with my strategy of looking for
trades in the first couple hours of the
US market open. And the most important
takeaway of what this did is it allowed
me to focus on one simple strategy
instead of trying to capture every move
or you know constantly add more things
to the chart either indicators or
learning more patterns to try and
increase my win rate. Because you know
logically the more you learn about
something generally in life the better
you are at it. Well when it comes to
trading more is not better. More is
actually less when it comes to trading.
Learning more and more patterns or
strategies just over complicate it and
they don't actually increase your win
rate. And so that's why it's very easy
for people to get stuck in that learning
loop because logically it makes sense to
go learn more or learn a new strategy
but it doesn't actually work that way.
And so I would highly recommend just
focusing on learning market structure,
not really using indicators. You can use
one or two, but do not have a ton of
them. The simpler the better in the
strategy, I think, because there's so
many variables when it comes to trading.
If you have too many things you're
trying to check off on your list to get
into a trade, you're never going to get
into a trade and it's going to be
impossible to start tracking. And when
you start journaling, which is something
I highly recommend you do to actually
figure out what's working and what's
isn't because there's going to be 15
different things that you need to be
working or not working. And over time,
that's going to be impossible to really
know what's making you consistently
profitable and what's not. But what I
highly recommend doing with your
strategy that you decide is you need to
write out a plan. You need to make a
trading plan to consistently follow.
What you're going to be doing every day,
your trading routine, what you're going
to do before you open the charts, how
you're going to look for trades, and
prep for finding those trades. And then
once you are actively trading, and
you're in a spot where, okay, what do I
actually do when I jump into a trade?
You know, for me, I have like a a
four-step simple checklist to jump into
a trade that every trade needs to match.
And then when I jump into a trade, where
is my stop loss going? How much am I
entering per trade based on my account
size? And then where is my profit target
going to be? Am I going to do a 2:1
riskreward ratio? Am I going to go to
break even at a certain point? You need
to have all of that laid out and not
just up to getting into a trade. You
need to have rules on how to manage a
trade as well because once you're in a
trade and there's real money on the line
or you know even if you're demo trading
it and you're taking it very seriously
and it's still intense, you're going to
become more emotional and if you don't
have a trading plan structure to follow,
you're going to end up emotionally
trading and making a decision based on
your emotions which is not going to be
consistently profitable for you and it's
generally going to lead to the bad
decision. Now, the most important step
when it comes to building your trading
account is how you properly scale. Now,
I've traded just about every asset there
is out there. I've started trading
options. I started trading stocks. And
what I've landed on after a long time,
and what I've realized works out the
best for starting a small account and
slowly growing it over time is trading
the futures market. I'll leave a video
up here that really goes into detail on
how futures work. I don't want to get
into it in this video, but the idea is
that you can start out with risking
about $20 to $30 per trade, depending on
the volatility of the market, and you
can slowly use that to scale over time.
They give you a ton of leverage as well,
which is important to growing a small
account or even trading a larger account
as well. And so the key steps that I
would follow is to start out demo
trading first or practice trading with
fake money no matter where or what
strategy you are doing because I find so
many students jump into real money right
away and there is so much about trading
that you are just learning even just
learning the platform you're going to
make mistakes and mistakes in trading
losses you money and so the switch from
going from demo trading to real money or
let's say a prop firm account is I
highly recommend waiting until you have
consistently profited for at least 2
months. Now the reason because of this
and that kind of lengthy time is the
markets no matter what strategy you're
trading the markets are constantly
shifting and no strategy is good in
every market. There will be people that
trade my strategy that do really good in
let's say a month time because the
market is having really good back and
forth reversal trades and every
aggressive signal works out really well.
But then let's say the market patterns
start to shift. the market starts to get
a little slower, less volatile, and that
trader now is used to seeing all those
patterns work in a certain way, and
they're not able to realize that the
market has slowed down, and they need to
shift how they approach the strategy
slightly. They need to be a little more
patient and wait for a stronger, more
clearer setup and realize that taking
that aggressive entry doesn't actually
work anymore. But instead, what happens
is they take that aggressive entry day
after day when it's not working and they
start to blow their account and give up
all the profits they had. And now they
realize, okay, the strategy just doesn't
work. And, you know, they go back to the
learning loop and they try a new
strategy or, you know, try and figure
out something that doesn't work. And so,
that's why I highly recommend trading
and finding that consistency for a
couple months on a demo trader because
you're going to go through multiple
market cycles in that time. You got to
remember there is some luck involved
with trading because it's just
statistics at the end of the day. And if
you're, you know, just have a good
profitable week, well, you can't just
say, "Okay, I'm a profitable trader and
boom, let's go off and, you know, now
risk
$50,000 on a trading account." Now, once
you are confident in your trading and
you make that switch, either switch to a
prop firm account if that's what you
want to do, but I highly recommend
starting out with a real money account
first with a small amount of money
because what this does is it slowly
introduces emotions into your trading,
which is the second key part of becoming
a consistent profitable trader. And you
have to learn how to trade with those
and manage those as you're trading.
trading on a demo account isn't going to
allow you to really unlock that full
emotional side of trading. And so
allowing yourself to start out with a
small trading account and risking, you
know, $20 per trade is what's going to
ease you into that. And then what you
can do is slowly scale over time. When
it comes to account size and risk per
trade, I wouldn't suggest risking more
than 5% of your account per trade. When
you're starting out at a micro scale,
it's kind of hard to go a lot less than
that. But as your account goes bigger,
you know, you get down to risking 2% or
1% or less than that. Risking a small
amount of your account allows it so you
are less likely to blow up your account
by going on a bad loss streak. And when
you're first starting out, you're going
to struggle to control those as much.
And so, you want to give yourself that
time. Remember, this is a marathon. You
want to give yourself that flexibility
to be able to bounce back and stay in
the game of trading. And so that's why I
highly recommend trading futures for
starting and scaling over time. The
trading platform I recommend and have
used for every day for over the past 5
years is called Ninja Trader. It's super
easy to start demo trading and scale
your account over time practicing your
trading strategy. I'll also leave a link
for that in the description of the video
or you can check it out using this QR
code. And speaking of strategy, I made a
little over $1,300 this morning trading
the exact strategy I look for every day.
I want to quickly walk you through what
that is so you can kind of see what it
looks like trading my strategy and how I
consistently profit off of just one
specific pattern every single day. And
so to zoom back here, I am trading the
NASDAQ futures market. This strategy
really works on any market or time frame
because all I'm doing is reading the
candlesticks and looking for, you know,
key levels of either resistance or
support in the market. And that's all I
do when I first start out. I, again,
going back to when I first started, what
I realized I can be good at is looking
for key areas of resistance or support
and then trading based off of those. And
so this morning what I did was I came in
and said, "Okay, well I see the markets
on a larger time frame has come up here
and bounced twice. It actually had a
little bounce here as well." And so I
decided to kind of keep track of that
swing as well because the market moved
up pretty quickly. Well, it could
reverse if it comes into a minor
resistance level as well. And so that's
all I do when I first come into the
charts is I look for the market to come
up into a resistance or come down to a
support level and then you know capture
a swing off of that. And so then I'll go
into either a 1 minute or 5 minute chart
and I'll look for a pattern to get in
based on that. And all I do is the first
thing of that pattern is I want to see a
big move up into that level. The idea is
for a reversal to happen is the market
has es and flows in it. A healthy trend
will have pullbacks in it before it
continues higher. Well, an unhealthy
trend often looks like this where it
just goes straight up in one direction.
And what that causes? Well, it causes a
rubber band effect. It needs to become
healthy again. And how it does that is
it has a pullback as it comes up into
this level. What I'm doing is, okay, I'm
seeing that it's had that unhealthy move
and it's started to slow down based on
just seeing these candlesticks start to
chop. It's not really anything super
fancy. You're just looking for that
momentum to basically level off. And
then what I like to look for is a few
key patterns in terms of candlestick
patterns. I use a couple different ones,
but generally what I look to look for is
a double top. You can see here it makes
one high. It has a bit of a pullback
with this big bearish candlestick and
then it has a second high. So that kind
of makes a double top. And for me, this
candlestick right here was a really good
signal because it showed that the market
essentially had a top. It attempted to
break out and it failed. And so what I
did was I put my trade below below that
candle and then elected to get filled
once it broke that low. And so what I'm
doing here is I'm shorting. I'm
essentially betting that the market goes
lower. I make money when it goes down.
You can do this in either direction.
That's why it works so well. Often I
actually find the trades to the short
side actually work better just based on
how the market moves. But then
essentially I just put my stop loss
above kind of the swing high here and
and and this double top. And then from
there I'm looking for it to give back up
this move. And so as a initial target,
you know, maybe it comes down here to
this swing low here. That would be
great. But it also the market opened
right here and just took off. And so I
think that this is an initial easy
target. That's why I put in a order here
for actually half of my size. And so I'm
risking about $750 here on this trade.
And I'm looking for about two times my
risk. And so this level right here is at
two times my risk. keeping in that, you
know, solid riskreward where this
doesn't have have to happen or work
every time for me to be consistently
profitable over the long run. And then
from there, it's kind of just letting
things play out and waiting for the
market to move. And so from there, if I
just zoom forwards here a little bit
because it is on a 5-minute chart, you
can see it moved down pretty quickly.
And that's how that rubber band effect
works is it essentially moved up here
and then snapped back to this area. And
so I took half of that trade off,
captured about, you know, $750 because
that's half of 2x and half of my size
off. And then from there, I thought,
okay, if we rip down to this level, I'll
probably take off the rest there. And
that would be a sick trade. But if we
come down here and it's likely that we
find support down here because that's
kind of that initial spot where it's
given back that rubber band. I also move
my the rest of my trade down to here
which was essentially two times my risk
in terms of profit. And essentially my
plan was to use a previous candlestick
high as a trailing stop. It made this
big move. If it gives that all the way
back up, I'm happy to get out there and
move on with my day. And so it closed.
It knocked me out there. And if I just
pull up the actual chart from that day
to kind of show you what happened is it
pretty much bounced there and started to
chop around. And so that's why it's
really good to get out on limit orders
and again not get greedy. And this is
stuff that you're going to have to learn
how you trade and deal with. I highly
recommend scaling up over time slowly.
Start demo trading on something like
Ninja Trader. And as well, don't forget
about that 90-day trader road map that I
mentioned that will lay out even more of
this process that I highly suggest that
you go through. If you want to learn
more about my strategy and how I
consistently execute this strategy every
day, check out this video right here.
It'll go into way more detail than I
have here.